your way into jackass was very much
the same as dave england you guys were
like uh like a package deal
um well i was snowboarding up in oregon
dave had moved up there i'm
from oregon um and uh
david so dave england got in and he was
like yo
no it was actually whitey my friend
whitey oh yeah whitey okay
told those guys because we were filming
stuff up there just funny whatever gags
snowboarding stuff and had written a
couple ideas
and so they flew up there to film the
pilot
uh with dave and myself because the idea
that i
had turned in they were just like oh
what that's crazy okay let's do it but
what was that idea like urban kayaking
oh there was so many urban kayaking
blind driver
um all the danger aaron like extreme
scooting like that whole character
you know danger what was the gnarliest
the pogo stick this this shirt
i love that dude i love when he pogo
sticks onto the skateboard it's one of
my favorite
this is actually a shirt i had made um
by mikey boss dog and he he did this
graphic for me i said i
all i want is a pogo stick i want my
orange jumpsuit
and my pogo stick from the first skit i
ever filmed and that was that was the
first game
that was um i showed up just to god that
was such a genius
too i know it's doable i couldn't quite
figure it out
but i mean how many tries did you take
on the the
that you mean just the the pogo i would
imagine that you would have trouble
committing to that
no no trouble committing i full
committed back in the day and i still do
you know you've seen it
and this was you you did a pogo stick
right on to escape yeah i was trying to
basically become the first pogo skater
yeah and that's why i made this shirt
and and so it's pretty good that's great
man i became the first
stilts skateboarder there you go and uh
wow did that [ __ ] me up i don't think i
ever saw that anymore i
didn't do i did it on stage at spring
break i don't even know if there was
[ __ ] footage rolling
and i landed just straight on my ribs
and like
i i didn't even break a rib i just like
bruised them right there because i feel
like i'm worse
couldn't laugh dude laughing hurt so bad
like and
sneezing oh my god yeah the worst and
when was the first time that you guys
met
well so back to this pogo thing um i
showed up
on for the pilot this was like way
before we even had a tv show
so it wasn't even called jackass at that
point no no it wasn't it wasn't called
jackass it was just a
show that we were trying to sell to
either mtv or comedy central
it hadn't been bought yet so we were
just doing them you know
you had yours was it on that trip when
dave england had the
the fake baby on the bicycle and crashed
the bicycle
um that was the f following
trip i think they came up where they
actually came up for
about a week to film that first pilot we
did
was two weeks or two two days it was a
weekend shoot we came up
and i showed up dressed as danger aaron
for no reason whatsoever i just showed
up in that
the danger aaron outfit with that
because you care about leaving people a
legacy of entertainment yes
and i figured what better way to just
hug myself off of things
was that sorry was that like the
character
you know danger aaron was it invented
for that or it was
no no it actually came from um uh
two years prior i dressed up as a race
car driver and we bought an ltd and we
we went backwards all through portland
and
uh and then the next year i didn't have
an outfit for halloween so i went
as danger aaron which was the race car
driver outfit and all of my injuries
were
which at the time at the age of 20 i
believe it was
a neck brace an arm brace a leg brace a
leg
all your medical paraphernalia yeah yeah
and a crutch
and and then i went for halloween as
danger aaron and then
later that you know next year whatever
when they showed up i still had that
costume and so i showed up with my
helmet and my
mechanic suit that you know has my name
or whatever
and then dave was pogo sticking and i
just got out of the car and i was like
hey can i try
and i and then i just went through all
through portland pogo sticking
bad it's a cute story but the reality is
that the name
aaron mcgee sucks
that's the real truth yeah but stephen
glover is much better
that's why
you're the first gilchrist i've ever
heard yeah you know what knoxville's
real name is
yeah we do yeah you'd love to say it on
phillip
john clapp what's this what's up he's
named after an std
but wait is clap spelled c-l-a-p-p it is
why i
don't know how the std no i know his
name is
i don't think it's spelt the same it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole yeah
yeah dude